Hãy hai bên thống buổi thủ tương công phù chia ở hôm mình mạnh hết cho biết
phương ông Pinh đã đưa ra và cách tiếp cận trong tâm
nhằm giải quyết xung tổ bình dợi với thái lan
vôm nhắn chẳng xung tổng lâu thang
giảm thiệu tóc độ và khôi phục chẳng thái bình thường
phát biểu tại lựa khách chương xâm bài của tế
tất co ông hôm mình mạnh, bất kỳ khu vực nào sợi cho xung tổng phản nhắn chẳng lan rộp
sử li nhắn để giảm tổ độ và nữ lực khôi phục của định
tổng tổng chẳng rất phản toàn hành vi tụi
nhắn lĩnh đau công phù chia cho biết thêm trọng vụ độ
vôm nhắn chẳng thái lan hội của thống bây
tại tình phản tây mà trầy tư tiên của chính phủ
các phù chia là kiểm soát thình hình
ngàn xung tổng lần sang các khu vực cá
và bảo đảm ảnh toàn cho bình xí y
nhờ bình pháp này, hai bên đã đặt được thật lượng bản xóo đúng tôn
nông thời vý trì hoặc bình hơn bà tháng qua
cũng theo thủ tưởng hôm mình hết
các phù chia đàn tiếp tục lực ngoại giao thông qua
bà bây giờ chung và bà bây giờ khu vực
nế đát được thỏ thận dạy hạ
hôm bây tỏ khi vọng cà buồn chia và thái lan
có thể kiết kết thịt định hòa bình trong thời gian
dạ hội ý cấp cảo a siàn sắp tới
tại Malaysia khác lại hoàn toàn cấp hành bây giờ ý
giao dạy đã nhiều tháng
sự kênh này, giữa kiên có tổng tổng mỹ đường đã trăm thăm dư